Amanda Seyfried is experiencing an odd  new pregnancy symptom my breasts can  always tell what's gonna rain no no no  not that but she says she can smell  electricity it doesn't get better than  that  a dozen in a new interview with  refinery29  the pregnant actress says quote I swear  to God I can smell the TV there's this  staticky metally scent heightened scent  is a common pregnancy symptom on Tuesday  EEG confirmed as she and fiance Thomas  sadoski are expecting their first child  together this is big step for me  the former co-stars started dating in  March after appearing in an off-broadway  play together every night 85 minutes  non-stop with this amazing actor Thomas  sadoski from the newsroom I'm like he's  been doing theater for 20 years um I  have never felt so alive  [Music]